guys Christ DC comedy.com for Ticky
wikies I'm in Salt Lake City and Denver
this weekend all the shows are sold out
I appreciate the good fans here the only
places left to see me January 12th El
kahon San Diego January 13th the wilter
Los Angeles and then we have February
2nd in Nashville Tennessee February 3rd
in Washington DC and February 8th in
Reno Nevada those are my last dates
Chris DC comedy.com for Ticky wikies I'm
really proud of this hour so come see it
come see it live
all right guys I have one date left of
this two-year tour it's in wils Bear
Pennsylvania uh December 16th there's
only about 100 tickets left so get on
that if you want to see me perform this
m show for the very last time other than
that new year new tour with the guys
from the Impractical Jokers we're going
everywhere we're going to Highland
California Las Vegas Nevada Tempe
Arizona and we're also going to Miami on
that Cruise January 22nd and then we're
doing Hollywood Florida Tampa Cincinnati
Youngstown Ohio uh we're doing Foxwoods
Atlanta Georgia Mobile Alabama and a
bunch more dates are going to be added
just go to
impracticaljokers.com for those tickets
uh uh don't be a fake don't be a flake
don't run away from your feelings babe
don't be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate say hey bab hey bab hey bab hey
bab hey
[Music]
bab okay ready
yep let me spit out the com here we go I
don't want a lot
Christmas were you ever were you have
that guy that that got that in the
stadium oh yeah you did You' got
in the stadium no I I've done that you
done it oh yeah can you imagine being
that guy though oh my God that's
mortifying let's talk about mishaps in
stadiums after we sing okay F okay ready
I don't want to Li for there is just one
thing I need I don't care about the
presence underneath the tree I just want
you for my own more than you could ever
know make my wish come
true all I want for hey babe is
you yeah
how about this my personal trainer who I
go to once a week G really great guy
nice guy just you know deep in you know
Queens New York never you know whatever
deep in the heart Queen New York he goes
uh we we were doing uh chess presses the
other day and he goes um he goes yeah
yeah
thanks you like that license plate and
he goes and he goes uh he goes um yeah
he goes you know like with travel and
all that you know that it's very
difficult to to maintain muscle with
traveling because I had a client who
traveled a lot once and I was like oh
you know thinking like oh you know like
I was like oh what were they travel with
like a Salesman he goes uh no was um
Mariah
Cary I said wait what he goes yeah he
goes I went all over the world with uh
Mariah Cary and he kept saying it as if
like you know Mariah Cary the you know
the uh the person who sold 500 million
records you know yeah he goes he goes
you know Mariah he goes yeah I was her I
was her trainer all over the road
because she great great great person you
know Hero Dream Lover honey Mariah car
goes he goes uh he goes yeah he goes so
I said wait a second wait a second we've
been working out together for six months
you never told me you train Mariah Cary
he was like yeah he was like I trained
uh I trained Mariah Cary he goes I I
trained some of the I'm impressive he
trained a voice yeah I've never looked
at Mari Cary and said wow she's ripped
not that she's not I'm just saying like
yeah right she doesn't appear to me as
someone that's like oh man she hits the
gym hard right she's just a very you
know voluptuous lady she yeah she is
voluptuous voluptuous I don't know why
women take offense to that now do they
that it's a thing now women are starting
to take that was a comp yeah is that a
comp I guess a man would take offense to
being voluptuous yeah voluptuous is a
fun word to if you're a man you don't
want to be pearshaped what's more
embarrassing than a man having a big fat
ass right that's that's the thing I
think I'd rather have cuz I got a big
butt but I don't have like a butt that's
like outstanding where it's like oh my
God but like you ever see like a guy who
in like high waist pants and he's got a
big old butt I think it's just one of
the probably least sexy things a woman
can look at possibly but but it's funny
cuz female large uh butts are in very
invogue I love invogue it's it's all the
rage speaking of big old butts stabos
halak halikas stavi baby has a special
on Netflix and it's awesome I don't know
if you've seen it I watched it yesterday
it was awesome I started watch is the
best he we love him I I I posted about
it uh yeah check it out if you haven't
stav's the best I started to watch it
last night and then I uh indulged in um
some stuff that put me to sleep what
what do you mean I smoked oh you smoked
okay okay I thought you meant like you
watched somebody else's special and that
won't put you to
sleep now V let me ask you this as a
Greek woman stav's a Greek man does he
because he just kind of is so confident
in his look he's not what you would say
traditionally handsome former guest if
you don't former guest stavi could you
see how women could be like I think
stav's dope and and hot absolutely yeah
wait do you think are you do you think
savi's cute I think he's cute he's
attractive really yeah wow I I
absolutely think that because he
completely owns his look and that's all
it takes is to be sure and confident
about yourself and that's it well yeah
he owns that look he cultivated and owns
that well that's what I was
thinking because when I'm watching when
I'm watching this special I'm like I was
a woman I date this guy yeah you know he
seems like a blast oh my God he's so fun
yeah I mean I know he is but if I was
like a woman I'd be like oh what I'm
intrigued even when he had no tooth I
was like I kind of love this I love the
no tooth I mean he literally pulled it
out I'm like that looks great yeah it
looks great it's it's he puts out a
calendar every year it's phenomenal go
on his website stavos Halas 2024
calendar it's all different looks naked
he does it it's so it's it's the best
get head get hbrary instead of February
may I see your
titties Munch instead of
March for sex the May the may I see a
titties the picture was him completely
nude sitting on his couch with a gun
up oh I love it man that's great I I
remember when I first saw him taking
pictures with uh Mato when they used to
do like the yeah cuz Mato is like a
human Matteo's a muscle with skin
wrapped around it I don't know what I
don't know what what he eats and what he
does to do that Matteo Lane he works his
ass off in the gym I mean he's in the
gym 2 hours a day he says though he he's
he he doesn't he he he cooks and eats
pasta how's that possible how are those
two things possible because like they
say make you got to make your own food
it's when you're going out to eat and
the restaurants is when the issue comes
but if you're making your own food you
can control it and it's and you can eat
good healthy foods yeah but like M Mato
he's a phenomenal cook he's come over
and cooked at the house he's amazing but
he also works hard in the gym and he
said genetically he's predisposed to be
skinny not fat so if he stops working
out he just gets more and more thin he
never really puts on weight so that's
just a genetic kind of how do we know
how do we know we're genetically
predisposed
to well he just knows that he came from
skinny well he's just always been skinny
like you you I but I used to be skinny I
used to be a piece of
I said was I think you should leave
I used to be so skinny and now I would
think I wasn't predisposed that way so I
just changed though they used to call me
the stick really yeah s the stick yeah I
like
thin sound as a kid um do you watch on
Netflix first of all two things I've
watched on Netflix I want to talk to you
about one the House of Usher I have not
okay the House of Usher which I was not
watching cuz I thought it was genuinely
about Usher the singer sure so I thought
like for for Netflix I you could have
just I thought it was about when he
lived with Diddy no it's about it's
about ush the family's name is the Usher
family okay but which I thought like
marketing for Netflix like they
shouldn't have they should have just
picked another last name because so many
people think it's about Usher and it's
not but the House of Usher it's
phenomenal it's based off Edgar Allen
pose the Raven oh okay so it's
fascinating and it's one of those things
where like the first episode happens and
you're like what's going on whatever and
then you keep seeing this person and
then you start to realize that every
time you see that are you giving
something away no you start to realize
that every time you see this person the
same actress someone in the family is
going to die in that episode but you
don't know how you don't know which one
you don't know what
R so it's like as you're walking as
you're going through the episode you're
like oh snap but you realize that you
realize that so when I asked you is this
going to be giving something away and
you said absolutely not what were you
thinking I guess I did give it away yeah
cuz that's something you found out and
realized I'm like oh sh good point yeah
no but it's okay yeah I'm more concerned
I'm more like why did you not think that
was good but it doesn't ruin anything
right ruin right right like like that'
be like if you're like hey don't give
anything away about stabby then I tell
you his closer word for
word um I I but I thought it was a
phenomenal show it's one of those ones
where I was like literally and you know
what's a nice thing that's happening now
is my 2-year-old's too young but my
13-year-old and my 8-year-old they're
starting to watch like more adult stuff
with us cuz we're allowing them because
you know especially 13-year-old I mean
he knows what the hell's going on you'd
rather him be watching stuff with us and
locked upstairs in his room you know
what the hell's going on up there you
what going you don't want to know what's
going on you don't want to know just get
a poncho so so so I it's nice that like
we're kind of watching this kind of like
more adult things because it's tough
sometimes when like your kids are little
two year-old is watching the Full House
yes yes she's like Dad to quot the Raven
yes so but it's kind of cool to like
tell my kids like about Edgar Allen Poe
and like you know the little bit that I
know about him and they're like oh cool
like for the first go to his grave in
Baltimore yeah yeah I and I went to the
site where he died he dropped dead on
the street oh I that was outside of what
it's like Kennedy's Fried Chicken what
was that right yeah that's it was out it
was outside um um The Crab the crab
Feast it was outside of live crab Feast
podcast think um so basically though but
it's it's an amazing show it's highly
recommended and another show is you know
how like Netflix is doing this like how
to be a dictator was one now they just
did one how to be a mob
boss and one of the episodes on how to
be a mob boss was about a sicilian mob
boss I'm forgetting his last name but
he's very famous in Sicily guli guli and
then what they would do this is how sick
people are what they would do to like
make you never f with them is they
kidnapped this rival mob boss's son okay
they kidnapped his son they cut his arms
off while he's alive 16-year-old kid
they cut his arms off is this real or
this real this is real real they cut his
arms off and then they let him get back
to the house like right in like his
mother and father's like front yard and
then he's there like with no arms and
they like in shock but at least they
have their son back and then they shot
him in the head with like a sniper rifle
in front of his mom and dad's house so
like put you through like this mental
torture and then like kill your kid in
front of you just so you don't mess with
them it's like I want that the first
thing I would do would say my life is
over and my only thing I'm doing to do
right now is is is murder you and your
family yeah that's it it Mur you at
least I'm not going to murder the kids
but like well that's what it is that
rival mob boss then takes a vent data
and I forgot exactly what happened but
it's one of those there's other ways to
do it there's so many other ways to do
it I me also one of the other like what
about just killing like I mean don't but
like you cut his arms off let him ring
the front door and then shoot him yeah
it doesn't make you could have let him
ring the front door with the arms on and
shot him there wouldn't have been much
of a difference exactly it doesn't make
any sense yeah it was stupid that's
that's crazy I know I was watching maybe
the Moss is an arms dealer
that welcome back thanks it's good to be
here good to be back good to be back um
but it was oh 10 most shocking reveals
crickets by the way from and and pimp
it's a
BBC yeah um let me see go down
um please tell me you watch the golden
Bachelor no all right I'll talk about it
too what do we got Al Capone quit school
to become an entrepreneur I I think I
feel like I knew that oh this is just
mob stuff yeah I know I know his two
mentors Al opponent two man go down to
one what's number one I like to I can't
do the list I want to just know number
one that's all for power Pablo Escobar
started as a Sig cigarette Smuggler okay
what's number two oh yeah James Whitey
buer do you know Whitey buer is
unbelievable that story you know about
him yes and no he was the you know head
of like the wasn't he still alive
recently he was on the run for like 30
years living as an old man in San Diego
maybe came to one of my comedy shows at
the maybe it came to one of my comedy
shows at the American Comedy Company
maybe he would have come to one of my
comedy shows in elone California I
played it January 13th I love elcone
January 12th I'm sorry I know that
you're playing eloh the aloh theater
theater yeah people have been commenting
I to be careful because it's dangerous
area now one of my favorite shows of my
tour was in elcone at the elone theater
yeah and then I'm doing the wilt turn
theater the next night one of my
favorite I did it those back toback
nights I did it and I I was like
hesitant about LA and it was gang both
shows were on unreal alcone and wilter
but the tickets are not like flying
isn't there a pro did you have not a
problem but like it's not selling as
quick as everything else but I was
thinking La there's going to sell it's a
big city but it's not the last minute do
you remember I got there I got there but
I don't I don't remember I just got
there with LA and with alone as well Al
I had alcone was good yeah see I'm
having an issue with it was one it
wasn't like you know right but the
crowds were unreal and the W turn is
beautiful right beautiful right yeah so
nice and the whole downstairs area it's
like really really cool it's like old
Hollywood like kind of it's fun it's new
but it's old January 12th and 13th
that's fun uh I uh that's when I start
up again with the Jokers too and I'm not
in good places though and like well
actually you know I am I'm in Highland
California but I don't know where
Highland California is where is Highland
California when I say I'm not in good
places I just mean I don't know what the
hell that is then I'm in Phoenix and
then somewhere else but anyway just in
Phoenix elone means the I think elone
means the drawer the drawer yeah or the
table I don't know I I asked them what
it me they told me and it was 20 minutes
before I started my set I was teeing off
on the name and it was so I remember
that I'll never forget it there's got to
be a thing I'm sure people call it El
coones yeah I left my wallet in elcon I
left my wallet in El coones I don't even
know what coones means does it mean
balls I think it does I'm sure it means
something that and then that means balls
tell me about the golden bachel I've
never seen it the only thing I've had is
a golden Oreo and a golden shower SE
okay those are both good things okay you
try them once at least I tried I say try
everything at least once golden license
plate and you know what's funny the
golden sh
kind of fun golden Oreo disgusting
disgusting anyway um I never seen a
Bacher before in my life let me pref
preface it with that I know from pop
culture I know here's a rose whatever I
know from Jared freed I don't know
anything about it sometimes some of the
names get really popular and I might say
oh is this person a bachelor person but
I know nothing about it
so the golden Bachelor was about a
72-year-old guy trying to find love
that's him his name is Gary which by the
way it's not Gary it's Gary which I've
never heard in my life g e r y g e r y
or g e r r y Gary they like oh Gary it
annoyed me for the first three episodes
and I got over it Gary this guy my guy's
name's not Tony it's Tenny yeah right so
this guy's 72 and then there's like I
guess I will say 20 women all between
the ages of 60 and 75 Gils yeah Gils and
they were all is that 20 women it's
might even be more and dude I I was like
I don't want to watch this so I watched
the first episode and it is
fascinating and it is I I was completely
hooked and you know it's genuine it
wasn't trash television I thought it was
going to be like you know how like these
dating shows they're all like fighting
and they're you know it's all like
they're embarrassing themselves on
television really this was like they
were all supportive of each other well
put together they had all different
stories and all different lives and they
talked about you got to know them and it
was so touching and it was about these
people trying to find love after their
spouses have passed 20 30 years ago
recently people that have been married
50 years people that haven't been in a
relationship in 30 years and it was like
so like I I cried like nearly like half
the episod about like going to like a
room and having sex or anything no not
at all no no no it's and it was it was
it was these were the these were well if
you're not going to if kidding no I'm
saying if you're going to watch it you
might not want to see what that was cuz
it's kind of a little bit of a a spoiler
but Gary Turner listen to me I say watch
it I think he I think he get something
from it really yeah it was corn it's
corny but it's also like really really
like touching and moving it's only like
Eight Episodes or whatever is it over
now it just ended this week did he pick
a surprise one that you couldn't believe
he picked that one uh he picked one of
the I had narrowed it down to about four
and he picked one of the four right well
there she is that's the one he pick so I
guess you no secret for you um here we
go well listen when when I'm getting
tickets the only app I use is game time
it is the only ticketing app that gives
you complete peace of mind with your
purchase you see the view from your seat
before you buy you know exactly what to
expect when you arrive it's awesome they
have deals on tickets right up to the
start of the event and they even honor
and even an hour after it start it's
still the place for last minute tickets
listen there's a lot of ticketing apps
out there there's a you know things can
happen game time always delivers and
what I love most about them is the game
time guarantee it literally it always
gets you the best price if you find
tickets in the same section and row for
Less game time will credit you 100% 110%
of the difference that's amazing they
got Zone deals where you pick the
section and Game Time picks the seats
for Big Time Savings I love it you get
exclusive Flash Deals and sponsored
deals with tickets for football baseball
basketball concerts comedy theater and
more anything you want to do game time's
got it all and PR all the prices show
you your your total upfront no hidden
fees or surprises you know exactly what
you're getting into and you know that
you're getting a great deal so right now
download the game time app download the
game time app create an account and use
code hey babe for $20 off your first
purchase terms apply again create an
account and redeem code h y b a for $20
off download game time today last minute
tickets lowest price guaranteed hello
fresh baby America's number one meal kit
you know much how you know how much we
love it we talk about it every day I use
it every day with my family it's taught
me how to cook it is the only food I eat
hello fresh say hello to a stress less
holiday season with the help of
hellofresh skip the grocery store and
save time with easy tasty re recipes
delivered right to your door is the
season for giving and Gathering and with
hellofresh it can also be the season of
saving actually save money this month
with fresh recipes delivered cheaper
than takeout and with pre-portion
ingredients you will never ever waste
your money on excessed food I just love
it did you know hellofresh does more
than just dinners from easy breakfast to
start your morning off right to
10-minute lunches on satisfying snacks
both adults and kids will love
hellofresh has tasty choices for every
single Meal Time occasion and the best
part no grocery trip required baby they
have over 45 recipes and more than 100
seasonal add-on items to choose from
every week so it's easier than ever to
find something everyone will enjoy I
love hellofresh it is awesome after a
full day of work there's still so much
to do but with hellofresh I don't have
to worry about it anymore because they
do the busy work for me pre prepackaged
ingredients I do it with my family it's
a great family U bonding uh experience
as well so I can't advocate for
hellofresh enough right now you're going
to get a sweet discount if you go to
hellofresh.com
heyab free and use the the code hey Bap
free for free breakfast for life let me
repeat that I am not kidding
hellofresh.com Bap free use the code hey
Bap free free breakfast for Life folks
okay one breakfast item per box while
subscription is active that's free
breakfast for life at hellofresh.com
heapfree with code heyab free hellofresh
America's number one meal kid there was
there was a bunch of curve balls there
was a a little bit of a drama at the end
it was hard it was hard to watch a lot
of crying what about how they like in
the bachel they go and meet people's
parents they did that what do they do
now but are their par their kids oh they
kids yes they met their kids yeah uh
anyway all right so you've never seen it
but uh that's cool but but I enjoyed it
there would have been stuff to talk
about if you had seen it well I'm
probably not going to watch it because I
would assume Jasmine's watched this
already and and and hasn't told me has
just kind of internalized something
she's seen on the show that I'm not
doing and I've been yelled at about it
so I'm probably not going to see it so
if you want to talk freely about it I
say we talk freely about it and let me
just see if I let me let me it's fine so
the thing that was wild for me about it
the most was first of all you never
think about when you when we will be
that age and if we will be with someone
or not or if we lose a partner or not or
when you lose a partner or whatever it
is and if you haven't had like a
relationship like that in a very long
time like what that does to the human
being and the an accomplishment as a
human being just to even make it to that
age and still be relatively healthy
correct yes right so it starts to put
your mind there and then you're like oh
and then you kind of empathize and you
kind of relate to these people and then
you know most of the women real quick
just line for a movie Just you have to
get it yeah you know most people would
empathize with our situation what is our
situation
dad I do think most people would
empathize with our situation what is our
situation
dad any clues at all comedy I'm
streaming two words comedy two words
comedy main actor you know very
tall Legend you know him Shaq
[Laughter]
no it's
Kazam I don't know if he did something
like you know like say at home Dad no
it's it's it's he's involves it involves
painting Vince vaugh yeah it's uh is it
probably it's the uh the the uh the the
Crashers The Wedding Crashers Wedding
Crashers there it is all right go ahead
I just started to watch that Rec again
but I didn't see that part you so you
don't know Wedding Crashers like every
seen word for I saw it back in the day
once maybe twice I've watched Wedding
Crashers every SLE time it's on a flight
I want I love he's really funny in it
he's he's Vince one's so funny let me
tell you something in my opinion Vince
vaugh is one of the best comedic actors
all time and you know who else is one of
the best comedic actors and directors of
all time ever John favra unbelievable
what John favra can do fa I I call him
but well I'm just I'm just letting you
know because I don't want you in a big
Power meeting right or some type of big
lunch in with suits and then you say
John favro and in some way that affects
your life in the listen you know I'm a
fa I'm a favro lover but I said I just
said favro because I wanted in the off
chance that well he's listening we know
that you are just wanted to sound a
little different but I I doe you know me
I'm the biggest favro there is yeah I'm
a f you know I'm at all the favro bars
downtown yeah I love it okay I love it
Brett favro
[Laughter]
all right so golden Bachelor no no what
what what got me what got the hooks in
Me is This these people are very
vulnerable and uh they haven't been in a
relationship and some of them like I
said are widowed and they they've never
had the courage to open up to someone
like that again and and and get to that
place mentally and emotionally with
someone again and then they do right and
then this guy has to date like 25 women
and they all feel that way and so
they're all Tak taking a leap of faith
and like opening their wounds and their
hearts again after a long time of not
having for most for the most part and
then he establishes connections with so
many of them and then just has to dump
them I know and they are
literally I mean they're devastated
because they make this connection with
him and they're like I never thought
that he I would feel This Feeling Again
it's been 40 years I've never looked at
another person and I can't believe I'm
I'm falling love I forgot what it feels
like to feel this way my Everything's
changed I have hope with life I feel
happy for the first time and then he's
like you're out of here it's like and
it's like oh my God and it devastated
and it was like I felt so bad I was
crying like every episode okay I I
respect it and I understand but my only
but it was entertaining too right but my
only thing is is okay listen there's
always a chance especially when you're
meeting someone and going on dating
someone that they're talking to other
people always there's a chance it's
always in the back of people's minds but
when you are on a television show where
you know not only do you know they're
talking to other people you know the
other people they're talking to how
could you get allow yourself to get that
close and fall in love part of the
process of watching this I say all these
things out loud I talk to the television
I talk out loud I say but but but this
has been x amount of weeks and this and
this and that but they even address it
themselves they're like look I know you
know I know it's been like you know six
weeks and I know I've only been on five
dates with him but uh you know and they
say I know I didn't I didn't think this
could happen but I'm I'm in love with
this guy you know like I and and and
they explained it and I'm like I guess
so I mean look when you're when you have
not even looked at someone that way or
attempted to be on go on a date or
anything and you put yourself in that
position and then you make a connection
I guess it's like the floodgates open
it's like so they get hooked you know
they get like emotional right it was
depressing right hopeful but depressing
sweet but sad sweet but sad yeah there
was there was the yin and yang of it
which I enjoyed right I did on on
certain nights where I was wasn't in a
great mood I didn't watch it interesting
because sometimes it made me feel a
little bit down right uh empathetic
right so I was like let me not lean into
that but on nights where I was like I
had to skip a pep in my step I would
watch it you would watch it yeah and
there's only eight episodes and there're
eight hour long episod 10 eight to 10
they're 44 minutes like will there be a
golden Bachelorette have people been
saying so so Bachelor nation is a
buzz apparently what happens is in the
regular bachel the Le runner up becomes
the next other person so the last
Bachelor that got cut becomes the new
Bachelor and his last bachelorette that
got cut becomes the new bachel and she
might be the bachelorette assuming she's
not dead it it stands to reason we
thought they were going to make that
announcement they didn't right so I
don't know but the woman who got cut was
it was very sad because she was like
I've been my whole life I've been in two
marriages that they didn't treat me
right they they left me they
disappointed me they shocked me they
left me alone they left me brokenhearted
and she was sweet intelligent
good-looking lady and she's like i' I've
been I have no trust in anyone it's
always gone terrible for me I put I've
been crushed too many times I've never
wanted to do it again and then she falls
madly love with this guy and he tells
her he loves her too and what was her
name and he tells her you're the one
Leslie Les he ends up picking
Teresa no but and and and he goes on so
he goes and meets their families and
they meet theirs and everything's
cooking right and he's like I don't
really know about Teresa I liked her in
the beginning I don't know a lot about
her but Leslie I and he goes on this
date and it's the last date before he
chooses and you're like oh I don't even
have to watch the finale he's choosing
Leslie then he goes on his date with
Teresa she turns on the charm all of a
sudden they get into it they go behind
closed doors she reveals everything
about her life he comes out he's like
she lost her husband 40 years ago like I
lost my wife 40 years ago I didn't know
that like we Bond and he ends up picking
Teresa now
Leslie he he she just has a breakdown
right on the show it doesn't even get to
the final Golden Rose ceremony where he
chooses one he has to tell her
beforehand cuz he can't stand to let her
wait so he cut he goes against the
show's rules goes to our house and says
I'm not picking you wow which is I don't
think it's ever happened before that's
what the host said and he and he refers
to Bachelor Nation all the time as a
matter of fact we were doing a shot
every time he said the word Bachelor
Nation it's too much if you're watching
I think his name's Jeff he revers to
Bachelor Nation every other sentence
that's the only country I want to be a
citizen to Bachelor Nation but uh yeah
but but uh and then she breaks down and
she's like she literally starts balling
she's like everything you told me was a
lie he's like no I felt that in the
moment she's like we went behind closed
doors the cameras didn't see what you
told me you led me to believe you were
definitely choosing me you let me there
and then you just pulled the rug out
from under me well this is why I'm not
choosing you Leslie she's dressing so I
mean get over she just lays it all out
he's he's just sitting there like Jesus
Christ why all your husbands divorce you
yeah he sounds so annoying she lets him
have it to the point where all he could
do is like he feels so bad he starts to
cry he says this is the worst I felt
since my wife died but then all after
after a while of him going you deserve
this I'm so sorry she just keeps loing
he goes I'll see myself
out and he just gets up and walks out
she's like yes see yourself out yeah I
mean it's but but spoiler alert okay but
do you think but do you think do you
think my question is though like I mean
some of that has to be not genuine it's
just can't I promise you I'm I am the
biggest cynic of this I'm the big
biggest critic this was genuine if I was
one of those golden B rettes like and I
said something like that and it got
really negative press like if it turned
on her some no it didn't turn on her I'm
just saying she was she was nothing was
bad at what she said but if it did if
any of these golden bouett said anything
or even the Boucher said something he
regretted you could just be like I have
dementia dude some of these women when
was 75 she looked like she was 55 5050 I
swear to God I I I swear to God I was
like they they played pickle ball they
did the pickle ball tournament one like
like broke her leg or
something where where's the obsession
with out of nowhere where is the
obsession with pickle ball and New
Balance sneakers where the hell where
has pickle ball come from everybody and
their mama playing pickle ball pickle
ball was dropped on us out of nowhere I
heard I remember the first time I heard
pickle ball they said to me um on the
show we we we we played pickle ball
coaches I hate people that sip like that
when they like this just purse your lips
you know like what what's the point of
that like people they do yeah he yeah
you do you have lips to put them out and
Stu yeah go
ahead when was the last time you used a
silly straw oh use them all with the
kids oh me too okay yeah I don't yeah I
use them all the time for myself but
yeah um sounds a pedophile what was I
saying what was I
saying they're going to come after no
Chester was coming after me well we were
talking about pickle ball just got
dropped they said to me they said to me
uh they pitch to me you guys will play
pickle ball um co uh instructors I said
what's pick and we did it on the show we
play Pick ball in how many years ago
this pickle ball instruction yeah was uh
it was two years ago okay not even so
recently not even right it was like this
season right of the golden B yeah and uh
that's the first time I heard it and
then I heard it every day of my life
since then every single day of my life
Ben you play pickle ball right no I play
tennis actual tennis what's the
difference between pickle ball
because theying all the in the city you
don't have any I thought there was
specific pickle ball courts yeah and the
ones that were really meant for tennis
like they're now developing pickle ball
instead of new tennis courts which is f
but what is the what is the difference
between pickle ball and Tennis pickle
ball is like pingpong meets tennis okay
or paddle ball meets so do you have to
be less of an athlete then to play
pickle ball pickle ball is for more of
the population that well that's I heard
it was was it became it boomed because
of the elderly cuz that like the um the
elderly play tennis though yeah well
they play Pick A for reals though like
for real for real right for real smaller
as well so you're not running a lot got
it so that's why it's like so many
people play but don't sleep it is it is
still challenging you still I mean you
ever get into a heated game of ping pong
that you sweat like this is still like
imagine it's still like tennis with
paddles it's like it's and you still
have to run back and forth you know I
just think that it is could also be
played at a certain speed and I think it
I was told to found traction at the old
age like communities like they started
playing it for exercise and then it just
blew up and now it's like everybody's
doing it right but I mean this is like
this is the new like I don't remember
the last time something came on the
scene that no one ever heard of in their
lives it's it's almost like but see this
is what I'm talking about like how long
has it even been around like that's the
thing though like I feel like the
governments do like there's powers that
be that just Dro these things into our
cuz it's just it's just nowhere then
it's
everywhere the government I don't know
why it has been distracting us pick ball
has been around for 58 and2 years yeah
but so sometime back in the 60s the
government uh planted a seed I just I I
mean I bet you Russia planted a seed in
the 65 and now it's they they do that
they do the longterm no they do it's a
long-term I don't know what this is but
if the the way that pickle ball has come
out of nowhere how it was nowhere now
it's everywhere it's just it's it's
something is up something government did
something with pickle ball will find it
and if you find me hanging for my own
door knob know that I got closed same
thing as MJ and Anthony Bourdain pickle
is a reference to the throne together
leftover non-starters in the pickle
booat of crew races I made a woman named
Joan yesterday she was a waitress what a
nice name Joan I said ma'am you have a
powerful name I said you have a powerful
name there's very powerful women Joan of
Arc Joan Rivers Joan Jet I said there's
powerful women named Joan go keep going
well those are ones I said and I just
thought like she would have like a
response like oh thank you whatever she
was like is a steak medium rare or well
well done and I was like oh it's uh we
we would like it medium R don't don't
you not she was sweet but I was like I
just you know I would like to have a
conversation about your name Joan yeah I
was like my daughter's name is Delilah
it's in like the same realm as Joan it's
like not it's like an old school name
that's not too popular but doesn't sound
little girl walked in there and said oh
my name is Joan that'd be so cute I
would love it like you know like a
little boy is my name's George it's like
old but she was like she didn't want to
she didn't want to participate I get it
yeah I get
it well do you think you always oblige
when someone approaches you and askes
you things like that well I don't have a
very interesting name asks is you ask is
you I'm going to start going with my
name introducing I want to change my
name to Christopher yeah what is your
name not Christopher no my name's
Christopher but like I go by Chris to
Stephan but I want to start being I want
to start going as Christopher to stepan
or my or Christopher DDE e that's how
about hey bab hey babe with Christopher
and Salvatore yeah right yeah dude my
daughter signs her name in school which
the teacher like we don't have a problem
with it but on test she puts Delila
d.com that's her name she's she's she's
already working on her brand she'll put
first name Delilah last name
d.com and then she told me she's like
you should change your name to
Christopher D on stage I'm like that's
kind of like very gay but it's kind of
like a different name like if I do a
oneman show I'll do it as Christopher D
Christopher D yeah yeah I like that or
we we should do a whole episode where we
assume what that feels like you'll be
Christopher D and I'll be Salvatore V
and it'll be hey baby Christopher D and
salvator V and we'll see how and we'll
see what happens when we assume those
monikers yeah vanity a g and homeless P
homeless
P all right this episode sponsored by
betterhelp listen we all need therapy at
some point in our life I know I do I've
been doing it for a year I've been using
better help for a year and they really
are awesome I mean look whether or not
your family gives gifts during the
holidays you get to Define how you give
to yourself and the holidays are great
time to do that so whether it's by
starting therapy going easy on yourself
during the tough moments or treating
yourself to a day of complete rest
remember to give yourself some love this
holiday season I've benefited from
therapy um and I really think like you
could some of you know that you need it
some of you don't know that you need it
but better help makes it so easy if
you're thinking of starting therapy give
better help a try it is done entirely
online designed to be convenient
flexible and suited to your schedule you
just fill out a brief questionnaire get
maths with a licensed therapist and
switch therapist anytime for no
additional charge it is the season of
giving give yourself what you need with
betterhelp visit betterhelp.com heyab
today to get 10% off your first month
that's better help heelp
.ab again entirely online you don't have
to actually go to a therapist's office
and sit there in a brick and mortar you
just do it you start it when it's
convenient for you and they really do
have great therapists and if you don't
like the therapist you can switch at any
time they make it so seamless I've done
that a couple of times and they really
really really are thinking about you
first so right now go to betterhelp.com
heyab that's betterhelp
hp.com to get 10% off your first month
better help thanks for sponsoring the
episode what's up guys Dr Squatch is a
new s product I've been using I got sent
These Bars because they're with the
podcast now and I have to tell you right
this second I love them I really do they
are they smell so they smell so good
it's cool fresh aloe Bay Rum pinear they
have all these cool scents wood barrel
Bourbon my favorite is Birchwood Breeze
this is what it looks like um before I
had before they sent me this I really
didn't have a soap that I would use I
didn't have my regular soap this this is
definitely going to become my regular
soap um stuff to know about a high
performance natural products it's 98%
natural B corpse certified there's no
harmful ingredients um it just smells
great and it's a good holiday stocking
stuffer I'll tell you that much just
load this up in a stock and you buy
three soaps right now you get three
soaps free that's 28 bucks in savings
that's like getting each bar for $4 and
this is like a really kind of like
artisanal type of product this free sh
that's valid for new customers only uh
yeah right now Dr squash is offering our
listeners a huge savings all new
customers will get three free bar soaps
plus free shipping with any purchase of
three bars just go to drsquatch.com
heyab that's do Squatch D
RSQ ach.com heab to receive this buy
three get three uh
offer uh slhe babe uh to buy three soaps
and get three free it's time to get all
the daily routine Essentials you'll need
to start feeling good and smelling like
a man
today don't worry no one could tell this
kid's what is up with this kid's hair
pimpy I have no idea this guy shaved his
head and tattooed hair onto his
head and by the way he didn't tattoo a
flattering haircut onto his he tattooed
like a Russian 1998 haircut yeah that's
almost a little bit like what uh uh
flavor flave
uh uh come on uh uh Dumb and Dumber Jim
Carrey yes but but our friend uh
flagrant Andrew Schultz yes yes yes
Andrew Schultz he has a whole shaved
thing now it's like a 1950s throwback
hair like a it's like a futuristic but
also throwback haircut yeah um I've been
doing that lately I'm scared what
yesterday I tried to remember the name
of someone I've known for 30s something
years yeah but it's not and I I was
looking at the people I was with I was
like this is insane I this person i'
I've known for over 30 years I know them
know them I can't think of their name
yeah but that's because you haven't
thought about them in a while or thought
about their name in a while so other
things have gotten pushed the front
didn't happen in the past and it's
happening more and more now like I can't
I mean I Andrew Schultz I've thought of
him I I see him I see him online I see
like it's it's not like I haven't
thought of Andrew Schultz in 30 years
right it's not scary it's little scary
to me yeah but I think it's also you I I
think you had a big thing happen in your
life you know you you put a lot of time
and energy towards the special that's
over now that was in the Forefront of
your mind now your your brain settling
back to like kind of ordinary time as we
call it in Catholicism you're an
ordinary time now well I you around the
holidays and you had big things going on
but now we're we're entering ordinary
you're saying there's nothing at all to
worry about I don't think there's a
thing at all to worry about I don't
think you should worry about anything um
what would you rate your memory on a
scale of 1 to 10 10 being uh 10 being uh
Dustin Hoffman in Rainman mhm like
whatever and then one being like or like
one being like uh Robin Nero and uh
Awakenings I would say um my memory is
about a seven okay I would say my memory
is about a seven and is that fine it's
par it's solid solid what I have a
better what I remember most I remember a
lot of facts and like specific things
about like history but like my childhood
and things I don't remember at all you
see it's a reverse for me I remember
moments human moments in childhood but I
cannot remember history right see and
that's all I can remember but I remember
numbers right I do remember numbers like
phone numbers no like I'll like just
things with numbers like I'll if you say
to me oh I say 18 what do you think
of 18 I'm just saying it throwing a r 37
I don't mean it like that although did
you ever hear about 37 being the most
quintessential number that theory about
37 being the most common and
quintessential quintessential Tarantino
quintessential Tarantino that's a fun
quintessential Colin
quintessential uh wait wait we go back
see what was I saying I said I forgot
what I said just
now like if you said to me oh you played
the mo theater in Seattle in 2014 I'd be
like yes this was the capacity and
that's way we sold oh okay so so that's
the way your brain gets mapped yeah like
it's it's it's in numers like mat we'
spoken about his brain sees colors so
numbers are colors to him and different
so so he that's how he it's um called um
like automn I think it's it's it's um
it's basically like certain he
Associates a color with a number I think
that's what it is and what does that do
is that is that a benefit synesthesia
synesthesia is when your brain routes
sensory information through multiple
unrelated senses causing you to
experience more than one sense
simultaneously that's so when you're
yeah you think anything that he sees in
his brain is different colors it's the
gayest brain you can
have tasting words yes or linking colors
to number tasting a word well that's
what I feel like when you say hummus you
taste it I can taste the the it's it's
like just good enough throw edible thr
when you map people's brains it's
amazing because we all have the same
brains for the most part like you know
the same parts of the brain in the same
places but our brains what how they
function is wildly different from person
to person it's truly nuts how different
our brains are but you think that
they're the
same even this shirt is 150 out the door
still nuts
I think
you Dan
flashes wait wait what's your oldest
memory okay I believe my oldest memory
and I believe my first memory is me
being three to three and a half years
old okay that's pretty old that's pretty
old having a pretty scratchy throat my
mom going into the kitchen getting me
some type of tea or medicine and me
laying down on the couch watching basic
television we didn't get cable till I
was in eighth grade watching like
whatever CBS or or something like that
on like a old school Zenith TV and
seeing zi and seeing a an image of Dolly
Parton and falling in love with Dolly
Parton are you pulling my leg I swear to
God I was pulling my leg to Dolly
Parton but but that that's that's my
first memory that I really remember
laying on my couch seeing Dolly part
with a scratchy you remembered a lot
with a scratchy throat and again it
could be my memory now has taken on like
it could not be the actual thing but if
you're asking me today that is the
oldest memory I have and I don't know
what it was but I remember my mother
walking to the kitchen and and doing
something I and then me looking and be
like I love Dolly
Bon is that weird no she's she's a
looker a babe yeah what's your earliest
memory it's I I couldn't discern if
one's earlier than the other but my
amongst my earliest I remember was
Christmas we were living in the first
house that I was born in which I believe
we left when my sister was born so we
only lived there until till about I was
three or
maybe maybe four MH some same around age
three to four and uh my mom was getting
ready and I was laying on the living
room floor of my dad it was a blue
carpet and there was a mirrored wall and
the tree was up and she was getting
ready and me and my dad were laying on
the floor playing with two little
bendable with a bendable figurine of
olive oil nice I remember I got this can
of spinach and the the figurines were in
and you opened the can and I had a
Popeye and an olive oil and I still have
the olive oil you still have it I still
have it and it's linked to my first
memory wow her nose came off right oh I
thought you meant a jar of olive oil but
you're talking about olive oil popey's
wife yeah I didn't pull a jar of olive
oil out of a can of spinach cuz I was
saying why would you who who has little
why would you give a kid a little play
toy no the figurines like and we it was
like those one know those ones where you
little you just bent didn't they Bend
any any way a whole body and everything
there was a there was literally a piece
of like like bendable metal in the
rubber right yeah that's what and that
that was it and he was like playing and
making voices and stuff do you remember
Stretch Armstrong yes yeah I had one of
those they they they they come out with
vintage choice now they remade that you
can buy that now really yeah you tried
to break that right I yeah I think
I I think I break I think everybody at
least broke one of them yeah right I
mean it's crazy it's like you give it to
a kid and like you to you're going to
pull this as hard as you can in opposite
directions and it's going to snap or
someone's going to let go and it's an
immediate like I'm I'm putting you in
immediate danger with this no kids like
just pulling the thing like this he's
like you just run as far as you can
right that that had to be also a lot of
poison in that thing no syn every toy
from back then was not FDA approved At
All by anything ever loaded up you ever
eat The Playdoh oh yeah Playdoh orange
crayons I would eat Crayola all day
really yeah you ever go to the Crayola
Factory in
Pennsylvania seven times fun trip really
yeah I like it I never went it must
smell great smells great that hurts
psylvia yes so I said one time they
should have a Play-Doh cologne and we
Googled it and there was right yeah I
was like Play-Doh make the smell makes
you want to eat it the smell texture and
and vibrancy of it makes you want to eat
it yeah and you eat it and all bets are
off nothing nothing comes together there
no it tastes disgusting No I um I
remember what is the sense of smell
AR
Playdoh Plato is a philosopher so
funny uh unique scent form through the
combination of a sweet slighty musky
vanilla-like fragrance with slight
overtones of cherry and the natural
smell of a salted wheat based dough
sounds delicious and it sounds healthy
yeah it does it really does it does what
is the agreeable smell that's that's
funny and agreeable smell Playdoh yeah I
um I remember that that I remember I and
then I remember I remember I got a yeah
go go for it I remember um My First
Crush I remember this girl I remember
being in kindergarten and then looking
at this girl Jenny and being like this I
like for the first time ever I'm like
I'm like obsessed with this like what is
this wow what is this feeling like in
the movies it would be that moment where
you see it for the first time like the
meat cute like I remember and then you
ready for this yeah she's not an actress
at all she has nothing to do she's not
an entertainment at all you know you
don't talk anymore whatever it's just
kindergarten I saw her in a commercial
her and her for some you know like how
sometimes they do commercials and
they'll have like real people yeah she
was one of the real people I was like
look at that there you go you're like
she is a real that is was it like a like
a I forgot what the commercial was but I
was like is that Jenny wow but yeah she
was like it was one of those things
where I was like I was like um well this
is like I can't believe like I just had
a crush on her the she knew it too like
it was embarrassing for me but she was
like yeah everyone you you told them
right everyone knew it back then
everybody knew my our mom's knew they
thought it was cute like my mom felt
badine cuz my she just knew that like
this was never this is just never going
to happen her dad knew her dad was my
basketball he was a great it there were
such a
wonderful knew thees knew the brother
knew knew three or four crushes
throughout like k through eight and
everybody knew about as a matter of fact
in e8th grade I was we voted class
couple did none of them ever wanted
anything to do with me but I had a crush
um I remember my first day of
kindergarten and my first day of
preschool
wow preschool's teacher's name that I
don't remember but I remember I remember
I remember all my teachers names I can
go from kindergarten through 8th grade
and tell me tell you all my teachers K I
can but I preschool I don't remember I
think they just had like helpers can you
go k through 8th grade all your teachers
names yes okay I'm going to go so prek
we'll do okay prek for me Miss Schneider
okay kindergarten for me Miss Schneider
first grade for me Miss Schneider she I
had the same teacher 3 years in a row
she kept getting moved up and did you
appreciate that or were you like drats
no loved it love Miss Schneider second
grade Miss link third grade Miss mcnevan
fourth grade Miss wman who I had a crush
on fifth grade Miss choroni sixth grade
sister Mar seventh grade Miss crimmy
eighth grade sister Teresa principal
sister sarapen you you had a nun in the
eighth but no no other in no other grade
that's a good point six and the eth my
nun was two right I had Miss vital love
it for kindergarten first grade is Miss
delandro second grade was sister Rachel
who yanked the kids here so so hard one
time he bled third grade was Miss
Gagliardi uh who got divorced while we
were in school and went reverted back to
her uh maiden name which was Miss pero
and she was the sister of the drummer
Tony pero from the band Twisted Sister
by the way tell me you went to school in
stat on without telling me you what
uh fourth grade was Miss cahe okay she
was uh C cut she was easily easily 4
foot one she she was 4 foot one she was
a a rotund woman and she wore mumus um
they're back in fash fifth grade was
Miss demerist who I recently saw this
season I was filming in Jersey and her
daughter saw saw me and then called her
and they came to the location and they
went to the PA and said we need to speak
to him I'm a fifth grade teacher I
hadn't seen her since then everyone had
a crush on her then too right she looked
great she looked the same and I I I I
blew her mind I was like I remember when
you got engaged you went to the mall to
get a pair of reboks when they first
came out and you didn't know you get
engaged and she was like a and I told
her that's the thing these teachers were
in their 20s when they were teaching us
she was 23 like she was like a smoking
hot 23y old yes yeah yes and then sixth
grade was Miss Smith she was if I might
if I may say still myself the one I
liked the least out of every single
grade really she just had a an attitude
a chip on her shoulder her she didn't
like her job she wasn't personable she
really had a short fuse like I don't
need anything and and then one time I
actually I shot someone in the face with
a rubber band from across the room I
didn't mean to shoot him in the face but
she really went overboard with that yeah
uh seventh grade I had Mrs AO atio the
Hun atio the Hun who then got married
and became Miss couver okay and then no
sorry that was that was seventh but then
in seventh we got to we didn't switch
out did you switch out no right no but
in seventh grade and eighth grade we
switched for just for social studies
yeah and that teacher was Miss musio and
then so when we were supposed to get her
in eighth grade Miss couver went from
Seventh to eth and Miss miio went back
down to seventh and we didn't get Miss
musio and we had Miss cver twice but
miss musio out of the whole nine years
was the teacher that everyone was like
in love with they want and then you
didn't get her she was like 22 23 and uh
very very very good-look do you think
and every kid and we were in seventh
eighth grade you know every kid was like
Head Over Heels as a matter of fact on
the last day of school my friend Frank
went up to a desk and left him his her
his number she goes what is this he goes
this my number if you want to call me if
you don't want to call me yeah if you
don't want to call me I asked for my mom
at a sleepover even uh we found they
found her number I I wasn't there but
they found her number in the phone book
and called it and then her machine came
on and my friend while the machine is on
they were like going to hang up and my
friend yelled my other friend's name he
was like Tommy cloak oh sh and then he
was like and then he went Damen Bates he
and then they hung up and then the next
day in school she's like so I had people
from school call my house last night I
know who it is and like it was this
whole thing and you got but they wasn't
any real trouble from what I recall I
think she handled it really cool right I
from what I recall do you think that any
of your teachers are still working at
that school that you mentioned do any of
them still closed down about sometime in
the last 10 years but when it did yes
there was yeah see my first grade
teacher was still there dude my same
with st Maas where I went in Ridgewood
Queens there's still some of the same
teachers I don't know if any of the ones
I mentioned but they still work there
it's wild yeah and then uh and so and
then I'll I'll fast forward this I was
who was I with I yeah I might have been
I'll call it I was
in let's call it I was 25 mhm and I was
I I somehow was at a bowling alley on
Staten Island what do you mean somehow
that's what you do no I don't I think I
took my niece it was in the daytime like
I didn't go bowl country
lanes Cosmic Lanes it probably was rabs
yeah yeah not robs rabs rabs rabs rabs
Gary that's where it was rabs it was RS
rabs yeah it's Gary Gary Gary Gary Gary
and I was 25 and I was there with my
girlfriend and my niece to take her
bowling and I saw Miss musio wow yeah so
you got to think I was 12 12 or 13 13
let's call it so 12 years later right
maybe maybe I was a little older than
that maybe I was she was born in say she
was fine 2005 I I don't know how old I
was we used to call my Call 29 I was 29
we used to call my gym teacher luk Kang
I know I told
you I only know cuz Bowen's lost his
crap uh I was 29 so that means you had
16 years so she was so I was 29 and she
was 39 okay yeah that's how old I am now
approach her right I did not approach
her but I saw her from afar and I was
like wow it just it occurred to me that
we could date now right it wouldn't be
it wouldn't be 29 and a 39y old that's
not out of the question yeah and it just
blew my balls off because I was like oh
wow like I'm seeing her for the first
time since graduation and if she's
single and I was single I could approach
her and if she if she was took it if she
liked me we could have went on a date
right could have went on a date
I'll never know what happened with that
storyline in my life because I didn't
but it's nice to think about yeah so now
I'm 40 so she's 50 can happen now you
can even happen now if you're listening
and know you are Miss
musio that's it give us a call here at
uh us 1800 hey babe hey we should have a
phone number shouldn't we we should take
live callers well I honestly would love
to do that should we we could you know
we could do that we could literally
tweet right now call this number right
now and just put on speaker and do it
we one of our cell phones no we'll get
like a can we get like a we get like a a
Google number let's get a Google number
and let's start just it just works when
we turn it on let's do that for next
week because I would love to start to
call have people call in and just say
anything yeah let's do one full one
where all we're doing is picking up the
phone answering calls yeah see how it
goes all day but tweet it and you just
call this number right now so we got to
get something on yeah you know what I
want so bad right now fedini Alfredo
with grilled chicken and garlic bread
you can make that happen I can one day I
was sitting with my friend and he said
if I won the lottery I would eat Kit
Kats all day long and I said you could
do that
now shout out
Steve you don't need to win a everyone
just turned I was like just it hit 50
cents just go do it yeah but you're not
going to eat cuz you you've lost so much
weight you're not going to eat you're
not going to indulge in something like
that I'm drinking bone broth now wow
every that's another thing that's come
out of left field bone broth left feeli
for me I first heard about it like six
months ago and uh I thought it was like
but let me tell you it's all over the
place now and I'm right now this is B
bone broth with ginger uh vitamin C and
garlic you made it tastes like I'm
drinking Thanksgiving where did you get
it the
store what do you mean like nearby like
someone she they just went down and got
it like where they sell yeah spring bone
kitchen oh so this is a place that's all
bone broth I didn't know that but
someone said I'm going to get bone broth
I said get me one and they got it at
this place so it must be select bone
broth because that place now they're
making businesses out of the just bone
broth now yeah yeah because because if
you I used to drink this paleo bone
broth you would just sip it like if
you're like fasting for 2 three days you
eat bone broth all day nutrients
vitamins everything out the a I'm told
yes yeah they said this is one of the
best things you could drink for immunity
that and it kind of satiates you I'm I
feel completely satiated I haven't even
eaten today what time will we have right
now it is uh 121 in the year of all Lord
and I haven't had anything when's the
last time you atee last night uh last
night I
ate I ate a nice meal at around
8:40 8:30 and then did I sneak
later and then
around 11:30 before I went to bed I did
have
a three three triangles of a Toblerone
okay and I I I ate about 10 peanut
butter pretzel nuggets with that okay I
cheated you but hey but you're down how
much but I well it depends it depends
when you're talking about but in the
last I hit I hit a weight where it's
visible but I've been working at that
for a long time so people like w you
lost a lot of weight but it's been like
it's been a long time that I've been
like TR trying but how long but but but
how long and how many from the worst
it's been the worst it's been which is
probably a year or a year and a half ago
whatever I'm
down uh let me do the math 20
41 uh 6 47 lb this has been hey
babe don't be a fake don't be a flake
don't run away from your feelings babe
don't be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate say hey babe hey babe hey babe
hey babe hey babe hey babe